citizens of the reject Nation we just
got out of watching killers of the
flower moon on IMAX I want to thank IMAX
for inviting us I want to thank
Gabriella especially for inviting us
because she is letting us shoot here
right now when everything is cleared out
and we want to make this short Port
patience she is being so kind to let us
shoot this like obnoxious teenagers
wanting to make a little Vlog video for
you guys so with that in mind IMAX is
the best thing in the world the second
we were invited was one that we said yes
to right away reason why Martin scorsi
especially on my end between the two of
us is my all-time favorite director so
the idea of seeing one of his movies on
my favorite screen and I'm not just
saying that it is my favorite screen
yeah I have to see killers of the flower
Moon so undoubtedly a very bias I'm
going to be like yeah it's the best way
to watch this movie IM Max it all the
way but with that in mind like I said we
got to keep it short we didn't know
anything about this movie before
watching it we never did a trailer
reaction action for it all I knew was
scorsi dairo DiCaprio the two greatest
leading actors my favorite director has
done multiple films with and now he's
going to be directing them in the same
movie have to go see it and apparently
this is a based on a true story one of
the greatest things I can say about it
is it it feels that way it feels true
like the entire time out of a three and
a half hour experience it just Rings
authentic it never ever Del
into a Hollywood even when you think
it's going to go like a Hollywood Trope
it never goes to the Hollywood Trope you
think it's going to go to this is not a
Christopher Nolan period piece no no
there's nothing that feels Fantastical
about it you know no you're it very much
feels like a fly on the wall it has
almost like a documentary type quality
if you've ever seen like a Ken Burns you
know American history it has that kind
of Aura and to the point of how
authentic it feels um I got to tell you
guys what this movie is about something
again we did not know about which felt
like a big educational experience I must
say makes you want to read so in the
1920s uh in Oklahoma the O they
discovered oil which brought them a lot
of wealth and then with having wealth
you know sometimes white people step in
and they go hey let me actually let me
explain please please take it away what
did you guys do well you know we saw the
opportunity and we're like how can we
iate ourselves to what is clearly
something we are owed by just being here
at home clearly how do you plant your
destiny baby plant your seed and then
manage to take away the fortune and
maybe that involves murdering some
people so that way you can speed up the
process of inheritance I don't know
nothing Greg I don't know nothing it
explores that main topic a largely
forgotten part of History it also was I
I believe one of the earliest cases if
not the first major case of the FBI like
the way they talk about it at least in
this movie yeah certainly it feels like
it's a fresh occurrence you there's
already all this you know Federal
suspicion anyway so now to have you know
investigators coming out from there yeah
it is a cold film it is a taut film it
is one that definitely requires um a lot
of patience I will say that like the
first hour to an hour and a half like it
it does have it's like it is a slow
movie the last half of this movie is
where you really start to get a lot more
of like that payoff for your patience
where a lot of the intensity does start
to really unfold because a lot of it's
so like it's it's consistently
interesting but then that's when it
starts getting like oh wow there the
corruption is getting really intense at
this point but let's talk about the
performances really quick now obviously
DiCaprio the star of this movie uh he
plays a guy named Ernest who meets up
with his uncle played by Bob dairo Bobby
D Bobby D who is the villain of this
movie he he's someone who likes to you
know pose as righteous and a man for the
people and I'm I'm not one of these
other white people I'm one of the ones
who's good good with good ones I speak
your language I know your customs and
I'm here for you he knows how to take
advantage of everyone and it's one of
Dao's best performances uh in years
probably since the Irish and him and
DiCaprio do play off each other really
well it's a really twisted type of
because it's his uncle but it's more of
a father Sun Dynamic yeah absolutely and
it's something that grows and Es and
flows throughout so it's something
that's going to really give you the
weight of that Clash that you want
between these two heavyweights and then
you got Leonardo Caprio playing um I
think his third Southern drunk bumbling
idiot you're a [__] miserable drunk
yes yes this time the biggest idiot ever
honestly it's a it's a really great
performance it's very believable like he
just he's like a rotting pumpkin in this
movie you know he really is yeah and
he's such a sad sack Mushmouth kind of
guy and if he had any kind of like you
you spend the movie wishing he would
grow a spine but that's part of what's
interesting about the character in
general is how he is completely
manipulated and pushed around by every
circumstance around him except for one
you know which is uh the the third you
know kind of biggest performance of the
movie I would say which is Lily
Gladstone which everyone's highlighting
certainly for good reason yeah Lily
Gladstone plays DiCaprio's wife she is
one the one of the wealthy OS people who
uh you know DiCaprio marries in this
movie it's tough to get into it without
really spoiling anything like that but
dairo wants DiCaprio to marry her for to
inherit the wealth and the thing is
DiCaprio part of the complexity with
this character that makes him actually
interesting is no he actually loves his
wife truly yeah but her performance wow
I cannot imagine the torture she went
through truly it is a very it's a
restrained performance very when I heard
people praising her yeah that's when I
heard people praising her work I thought
it was going to be something where oh
she's going to get a bunch of big scenes
of of just monologues of tears and stuff
but it's the actually the opposite of
that while there's anguish in a lot of
scenes it it's a surprisingly restrained
but really she does command the screen
whenever she's there you know she really
does she has a great presence and so
much of the painful heart of the movie
is told through her eyes basically very
very strong there's a great like cast
all around what I loved about the
casting in in general is I didn't
recognize 90% of them I feel like
indigenous people who were cast the
Native American people who were cast
they they felt like they just real
people that they cast and I would even
say the same thing for the white people
who were casting this movie this is full
of of great casting acoss feel authentic
and yeah a bunch of character actors who
look like they were just plucked out of
the time yeah yeah like you eventually
get some of your more famous people who
do show up but it's often so late into
the movie it has that quality of the
movie being so imbued by its time and
place and the casting like this is a
movie that's very composed and
everything from the production designs
to the cast that fills those sets and
those spaces it all really feels again
researched and lived in that's one of
the best things I could say about it is
you could tell just like the analytical
details about this capturing this period
piece to the point where you do feel
like you're kind of plucked in time in
one of the harshest ways you can imagine
because there's nothing like flowery
about the way its emotionality is
expressed like a lot of times never
melodramatic the camera just lingers on
scenes you know a lot of times like oh
man we haven't cut away from this one
guy just talking for a very long time
there's a lot of great seamwork a lot of
Great Performances very performance
Reliant and I think the one thing with
the experience of it is the movie did
kind of weirdly out of three and a half
hours kind of keep me at a distance it
does yeah because it is so cold that I
never really got emotionally like I
appreciate everything the movie's doing
and I love what the the top I don't love
what it it's about but I I love that the
movies do in this story you know yeah
however I never quite got emotionally
hooked into someone's Journey you know
to the point where I'm on the journey
with them kind of the thing you'd want
out of a 3 and a half hour film yeah and
nor is it like a good Fellas for example
which is which is kind of funny to me
because there were ear marks of this
that are like oh even though it's
completely different from the things SC
says he's become famous for a lot of
it's actually a little bit of a mob
movie no it is certainly or like a crime
family crime family yeah just just Circ
of the old west but yeah a lot of that
like yeah crime organization made man
stuff you know yeah yeah it's the way
how he did Irishman which was a mob
movie that felt very meditative this is
kind of like that with a more of a
periop slant and kind of a dark dramatic
Western flare to it yeah yeah that neow
Western sort of Noir kind of thing yeah
as it has that like percolating drum
bass beat throughout yeah I really like
the music in this I thought it was
nicely kind of a blend of things that
would come after but things that are
also very rooted in Native music yes it
shines a great light on the horrible
atrocities that went down and it is an
important story to tell you can feel how
important this story is you can feel the
fervor behind the film making and the
writing behind it as well and while the
dialogue does feel very true at the same
time I could definitely feel the movie's
runtime and while I think the last half
is way more engaging than the first half
I still was never quite as emotionally
pulled in in a way that was beyond an
observation piece yeah it's there's
certain Fascination to be had and and
certainly things to ruminate on when
you're watching so many of the purveyors
of these atrocities both through greed
and mination and also through dim
wittedness and and the kind of painful
mess that all of that represents and the
thing for me was I really really liked
so much of the work that was on display
throughout the movie beautifully shot
lots of great compositions lots of great
acting like you said the Molly character
Lily Gladstone's character is the
closest the movie brings you to having
like an emotionally sympathetic eyeline
but even with her it kind of keeps you
at an arms length so yeah I wish it was
a little bit more from her perspective I
do too yeah cuz I I I feel like after a
while I can imagine certain viewers sort
of feeling like maybe we are dipping
into tragedy suffering porn a little bit
you the kind of thing ciles look
sure sitting for three and a half hours
I you know while it is an important
story it's also you know there are
arguments to be had about how not to
just just make it a slog through trauma
Town basically not to say that those
things aren't legitimate but yeah there
is a coldness that I could see certain
people maybe not being able to latch on
to I'm still really glad that I watched
it because I I truly felt like it's rare
I watch a movie where I'm really I
really feel like I learned something
from this movie yeah and I want to
unpack it and I want to like I want to
learn more I want to read about this
it's one of those movies clearly so much
about its message I actually want to
learn more about the message yeah
totally that's a good that's a good way
to describe it I think and that's not
just me being kind and it was the
feeling that I had like I had to look it
up after cuz I'm like man was this
DiCaprio guy just such a dumbass in real
life
after it does sort of remind it reminded
me of like of the master in that kind of
way where you have this protagonist who
you're like is this guy going on an arc
or a journey or is he just kind of
bumbling his way and and just being
direct is he just a true Pawn in this
horrible horrible game that you know
yeah has so many different touchstones
in American history from a technical
film making standpoint I would give it
like a like a nine out of 10 from just a
movie goinging experience I would
probably honestly just give it like a
seven out of 10 yeah we're probably in
in agreement like there's so much to
appreciate but if you're really going to
be swept up in the movie that's kind of
that'll vary yeah that definitely varies
I heard some people walking out who
really loved it and I heard some others
who were like eh and and I'm more like
no I got like two feelings about it and
those are my two feelings guys leave
your thoughts down below of what your
favorite scorsi film is thank you to IMX
again again we got to get out of here uh
pull us out with you guys for listening
to us
[Music]
talk